welcome to the next part of the default
repertoire series in this video we'll be
looking at the Kings onion which arises
of course here and I propose to play for
first e6 and now on actually I'm going
to recommend them more suggest more than
one line here it really depends on how
sharp you want the position to to get
and also how much work you want to
invest in the line to to play here I'll
be recommending on two lines that I
played quite valiant one main line let's
start with the suggestion that we'll
take I think released yeah I think work
at home so the same which is the little
move h3 um explained a bit later with
the idea like usually castles and now
Bishop g5 and as a setup on it's quite
interesting because its first of all
it's very very flexible and the second
issue is that black often doesn't know
any specific line against such a little
plate setup but if you look it up in a
database or online chess games database
you would see that white has quite
decent results with it on one on one
simple point here is that black goat
goes h6 you just drop the bishop back
and this is also one explanation why
white played h3 because without this
move
like would have Nagi form and would
harass the bishop further actually h6
already is a little bit of a second-rate
move he had some not advisable for black
to weaken the King side with h6 I come
to that later for Vanessa to show some
other line
so what does black play I mean as main
moves here a little a little point here
is that if like actually goes a five
this already is a big mistake it might
only happen in in blitz games but it's
still good to know that the simple
exchange and 95 already wins material
because of the pin and the hanging pawn
on c7 so like already has got huge
problems okay well if I might only
happen in shorter time controls so if
black wants to play 45 which of course
is a typical Kings Indian move then he
needs to do some preparation and the
most topical moves there is 96 which
covers c7 so this line that I just
showed with the exchange on e5 wouldn't
be possible so now one is white playing
on white plays Bishop b3 now e5 d5 and
now we've got an interesting position
we've got the closed center in the
middle which is very typical for the
Kings Indian but there's one important
important point here right of course
hasn't Castle short and he doesn't
intend to and one idea here is to play
the move G form the other the sample
line maybe create to unpin
the night in order to play maybe nad h5
and then f5 then why does really plays G
form and one one idea is to to play
nighty to to g3 which would be which
would which would be very nice to
control the f5 point so black will have
a real hard time to play a 5 let's say
97 which the main move also to to play
maybe not D to C 5 and then f5 now white
actually can play even a 3 and 5 and B 4
and this of course leads to a huge space
space advantage for white and black also
has a little bit of a problem piece on
a6 this 9 is not doing anything at all I
would think that
why does a bit better in this line
generally speaking this type of position
where white is able to play g4 is very
interesting because it really pushes
black back and quite often if he doesn't
know what he's doing
leads to almost automatic wins for white
because of the huge advantage in space
another idea here for black is to play
entirely differently just one thing if
you look at this position again
just imagine black would have played h6
at some point then white would drop back
to e3 and in this position the move h6
would be really bad because it would
just weaken the kingside one at one
point it might be possible to rip open
the King side with g5 or h4 h5 h6 is
just just a weakness so this is also the
reason why on the 6 move here h6 is
already a bit dubious um let's let's
look at something else c5 is also
of course an idea which is often played
then white goes for for the Benoni me6
Bishop d3 exd5 265 and this is some
pretty typical beam only set up where h3
and Bishop g5 are rather useful moves
and what we'll just continue with Knight
f3 and short Castle of course this
requires a bit of study of the of the
middle games but it's not a huge amount
of theory or something
and also what results are excellent in
this position so um h3 Bishop g5 is an
interesting sideline which is really
worth looking into
I think maybe the best line for black
actually is something like this and then
and then play really exact moves for
instance at this point we have mentioned
Queen e8 it's also possible to go for c6
92 CD 5 CD v not c5 Bishop c2 a position
like this but this is also quite nice to
play for white you still have the G
foreigner g3 idea but you can also try
to go for B form it's a very important
point that white is very flexible with
the king with this King he doesn't
necessarily cancel short in fact this
happens really rarely in this line and
this way doesn't give black on the easy
target on the King side because a lot of
kings in your play are really really
looking forward to to push f5 g5 and so
on to get in this simple I check on the
King so this is an interesting offbeat
line but it's it sound you'll find
really a lot of Grandmaster games played
with this for instance some you find
games by Afghani barrier for left circus
was an interesting play anyway so it's
it's it's worth studying another line I
might suggest as an offbeat try but this
requires much more work
in fact it's something for people who
really like to play extremely sharp and
maybe prepare something at home that
which is smooth therefore it's of course
the most aggressive way to play but it's
interesting it's interesting um for
instance black doesn't have so many
options here he can basically only drive
two main lines one is some 986 with the
idea to play our E 5 later an example
line runs Bishop d3 Bishop g4 also
possible instead of P sub 0 of course
you see 5 which leads to this kind of
position this one one one possible line
and this sermon I think should be
slightly better for white after Bishop
g4 let's continue a few moves yeah black
came up with an interesting tactical
sequence with e5 I guess this will only
happen if black really studied the line
every five in our c5 which is a very
nice point as it breaks up the center
white needs to play d5 now as they move
like a g6 CD for ya just Fox to pieces
because here the pin on a3 setting like
so d5 Knight takes e5 Bishop e2 and then
continue a few moves
and this position also looks a bit
better for white another entirely
different approach on move six of course
a c5 which is played very often and
there you can actually choose between on
a really sharp main line and another
line which is interesting and a little
bit less studied d5 is the main move but
you could also consider looking at d c5
Queen a5
there should be three Queen C 5 whoops
not here Queen e2 of course and this is
also interesting to to play Bishop e3
and short Castle to come and White has
got some some nice play maybe I'm the
king side based on the too aggressive
pawns on e4 and fi f4 and also a3 and
before might be an idea it's all about
grabbing space on d5 of course as a main
move which leads to
benoni tab position and this can get
extremely extremely sharp one
possibility for instance is here Ruby
eight and then white even pushes on and
this position on it goes on and on
white can play moves like a six six and
t6 or Bishop g5 is an idea 26 and then
Queen b6 and then I think even short
castle is a move Queen d2 it's it's very
sharp this is not the kind of line you
like to play well and think all of here
and think of all the moves at the board
something you want to study at home and
then really try to get your opponent in
the opening who maybe doesn't know
because
what is happening and you can just repu
moves you looked at before yeah it's a
matter of taste but it's requires a lot
of work to to play this way um another
idea could be Bishop g4 in this position
instead of rupee eight and another line
just to show how sharp this position can
be here would be g4 h6 and even h4 yeah
would give g5 to come you know it's it's
really a line for people who want to
attack in a very direct fashion so two
offbeat lines one h3 and which is really
really a solid line you can I think look
at maybe 10 20 good Grandmaster games
and study the kind of positions that
come up and then you can play this so it
doesn't require so much work fo on the
other hand is simple for for people who
like to invest a bit of time at home and
want to really attack directly so it's
it's a good choice here between very
aggressive and work involved and well
positionally well-founded line which is
also not without its points but you can
I think just play this after studying a
couple of games and try this out a bit
at blitz maybe and then you can also
easily try this in a in a long time
control game I'm in the next video I do
a second one on the Kings onion
I actually present the main choice I'm
recommending which will be the famous
variation of f3 on move 5 please also
watch this video and questions or
comments a welcome of course